hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast next-generation
sequencing to understand the function of
micro RNA and human iPS see cardio
myocyte disease models presented by
ulrich
raquel professor of pediatrics medicine
and physiology and Amy Turner project
leader micro RNA technologies research
associate one department of pediatrics
Medical College of Wisconsin
I am sorry grenman of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kaya gen for more
information about our sponsor visit WWE
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question located on the far
left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located on the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Ulrich Burke L and miss Amy Turner I
will turn the presentation over to them
great thank you very much for the for
the nice introduction and I would also
welcome everyone to our presentation
today so we're very excited to talk
about the the research in our lab and
the work we are conducting using human
iPS derived use flow point stem cell
derived cardiomyocytes as a disease
model and let me just start with a legal
disclaimer here which we need to post
related to some of the the products and
technologies we are using from our
sponsor today in this presentation is
just a brief outline on the the topics
of what we're covering today we will
talk a little bit about disease modeling
and the role of disease modeling in
precision medicine the use of human
induced pluripotent stem cells derived
cells in particular cardiomyocytes
we'll talk about a study cohort which we
have been working with as the National
Heart Lung and Blood hypercam cohort
where we have been focusing and studying
the genetics and genomics and precision
medicine for related to electric I Pro
trophy we will talk about our approaches
to use RNA sequencing expression
analysis for RNA and micro rna's in
relation to our disease phenotypes we'll
talk and introduces our overall
experimental study design how we measure
disease in our stem cells a drive
cardiomyocytes model and we'll talk
about some of the the methodology we use
for particularly for micro RNA sample
processing and sequencing and discuss
with you our analysis approach and the
the experimental results and provides
some conclusions for this and so let me
just start you know precision medicine
is now really gain substantial momentum
in in terms of how we would like to
understand it really describes disease
better and it really started out
obviously as many of you know and you
know for many years that genetics and
genomics and understanding the genetic
basis of disease was really the main
focus but I think as we as the field
matures and we really
learn more about the impact of genome
variation on disease phenotypes we
clearly recognize that just looking at
DNA sequence itself is really not
sufficient to really describe the
complex disease processes which
differentiated patients and categorize
the seats better and so clearly the next
steps in precision medicine to really do
advance the field is really go beyond
just genome sequence and really combine
the genomic information also with
functional analysis the next generation
sequencing particularly expression
analysis where we look at RNA in micro
RNAs and it really extends them this to
proteins and if we really look at the
overall circle where we start with a
patient as I said you know we're looking
at DNA we're looking at DNA sequence in
the next cycle we'll look at gene
expression micro RNAs we'll look at
proteins transcriptomics as an analysis
approach and proteomics but we move on
to actually look at cells and there's
phenotypes in cells and tissue
themselves and then extend this and
combine this again looking at the more
as an organ system and multi organ
systems and then really bring this
together and describe the disease
phenotype in our patients much more
comprehensively so it's really combining
all those those things together and in
in precision medicine and as soon as you
can see if we compare I have the more
epidemiological approach where we're
looking at just general risk factors
where we're looking maybe just have one
drug to treat or we're looking at one
disease by themselves we're basing
category patients just as either have
disease or not have the disease's you
know that often you know epidemiology
population based approach you use this
type of of concepts and and we really
look at the disease more as a very
general to see small but if we're moving
towards precision medicine I think what
we need to include in our analysis and
model and really take into account is
that you know every patient has a
specific environment you need to be very
specific and also in the way how we
treat a patient's for example with drugs
and ultimately the underlying concept
here is that every patient has in
a very specific disease presentation and
dead really then leads to this concept
you know what perception medicine really
stands for that we looking for a more
individualized and targeted a disease
treatment approach and if we want to
study a disease that obviously you know
this concept then leads to two kind of
the requirement that we really need to
be able to model and develop disease
models which are unique to to a specific
patients and so they're really the
foundation how we pursued it in our
laboratory here is is using the
technology of induced pluripotent stem
cells and just to review it is very
briefly you start with a patient um
collect somatic cells in most cases now
a blood sample you culture these cells
you ant four distinct potency factors
and these cells in culture then actually
regress and become again pluripotent
cells induced pluripotent stem cells now
you can take these cells differentiate
them out in any type of cell type you're
interested in now we're particularly
interested in cardio myocyte so these
cells give differentiators and
cardiomyocytes the advantage of this is
that the the derived cells and the IPS
cells are really as unique as the
individuals where you've taken is from
we basically carry the genome in the
model and if particularly if you are
looking at for example a genetic disease
or a disease with which is determined by
genes and by and large these cells
actually do recapitulate phenotypes
related to a patient's genetic genetic
risk and if you then do this not only
for one cell line but for a multiple
cell line and and use it as a disease
model I mean the advantage is if you
start with your with your patients you
make these IPS cell lines to
differentiate those in your target cells
establish a disease model what you can
do here is then you can do very
comprehensive phenotyping you look at
the disease phenotype
these cells are obviously also use for
drug screening for biomarker development
and in many ways you can say I'm
diagnosing these cells in the tissue
culture and you know as to treat them
with drugs and look at
like response you can also look at the
the response off your treatment now the
advantages if you characterize your
patients well enough you also have this
data available you have biomarkers you
have very comprehensive genotyping and
the really major strengths we see in
this approach is that you can actually
validate what you measure in your cell
culture with what you measure and the
phenotypes indices presentation what you
see in your patients and compared to for
example animals this clear correlation
of comparison validation of your
biomarkers I think is one of the major
strengths of this of this platform now
let me introduce you to you the disease
we are really focusing on and for many
years now we've been studying the
genetics and risk factors of let's make
eye prote Rafi it's defined by an
increase of the weight of your left
ventricle and as you can see on the
diagram here on the right side right
side at the major causes underlying risk
factors are high pressure we see this
also in patients with diabetes kidney
disease and age and gender in addition
to rates are well-established risk
factors and definitely hypertrophy is
now well established as a risk factor
for example in patients with
hypertension with high blood pressure as
a risk for hypertensive heart disease
which ultimately leads to heart failure
in the next slide here you see already
kind of a summary of the expression
changes and genes and pathways pathways
which have been linked to a cardiac
hypertrophy and as you can see here this
is quite a comprehensive and complex
pictures picture including many many
different diseases and networks really
contributing to to our disease phenotype
and in the following slide here is just
also a summary what we know so far about
the microRNAs which are have been linked
to a cardiac development play a role in
cardiac development Korea great
generation and then on the left side
attune to your cardiac hypertrophy so we
already have kind of a rough framework
off of genes and micro rnas and mRNAs
which play a role in disease process in
more of a general disease model
to another dipole of a deeper look
actually again into more the into
individual variations in these overall
models and dissect this a little further
as I you know told you before where
we're having we're using IPS drive cells
and we're working with the hyper chain
study and part of a NHLBI funded grant
we actually generated 250 IPS cell lines
from a subset of individuals which are
in which have been recruited for the
hydrogen study the hydrogen study itself
as a bi-racial core heart we have
african-american and Caucasian
participants we have very comprehensive
genotyping it's a family based study and
we already did genome-wide Association
studies where also they also have whole
exome sequence data available so it
really built the foundation for our
genetic analysis so we selected a
subgroup of 250 individuals and
generated the IPS cell line and it
really builds the foundation for for our
analysis of what experiments we're
discussing today so in the next step is
obviously we have to model also our
disease phenotype and what we did over
the years is we actually established a
high-throughput genotyping platform and
pipeline to characterize these IPS
derived cardiomyocytes
so we culture these cells in 96-well
format we induce hypertrophy this is
kind of a environmental challenge if you
want to look at this this way we induce
them with well-established induces of
hypertrophy like endothelium
phenylephrine
or isoproterenol we cultured these cells
and at the end really our main
phenotypic readout at the end of about a
four to six week protocol is expression
expression profiling but an also than
following downstream potential of
protein analysis and that really allows
us to look at pathways to look at
Network and understand the variation
between the different individuals and
different cell lines which represent
individuals in much greater detail so
the next slide you know one of the
question could be is like do t-cells
actually develop a hypertrophic
phenotype these cardiomyocytes and one
way to look at this is for example and
measure the cell surface area what you
see here in
and on the left side here if we
stimulate these cells with different
stimulants competitive control they
clearly increase in in cell size we can
also look at Cephas which is a early
immediate gene and there as well you can
see that the cell lines stimulated with
our established well-established
stimulants induces of hypertrophy these
cells actually do increase and change
the their fluorescence and 4c fast so we
also did some very some analysis where
we looked at the expression changes
related to a differences in micro RNA on
the left side here in red you see a
number of micro RNAs which are
differentially expressed in our model of
cardiac hypertrophy
in a snail line so what I really need
the next steps know as we're looking at
micro rna's obviously we can say we can
look at how in these different cell
lines now where we try to understand the
variation better between different cell
lines and differences between different
you know individuals and obviously is we
can look at we try to understand the
variation in the RNA expression in
different cell lines for multiple
individuals and we can do this in
patients with and without on individuals
with and without hypertrophy ask the
question what is the inter individual
differences what are the phenotypic
differences we can look at as we're
analyzing mRNAs and micro RNAs we can
look at intracellular interactions and
dependencies between mRNA and micro RNA
and you know what are the genes which
affected by that between the different
individuals what pathways are affected
and then we can also look at predicted
targets for example of extracellular
micro RNAs and we'll explain a little
bit more our analysis approach to micro
RNAs as they excrete it from for example
these is cardiomyocytes as they get
excreted in exosomes and so you can ask
what genes are affected by that as well
and what pathways are affected and so
with that the brief introduction of the
overall our study design and our disease
focus I'll hand it over to my
co-presenter Amy Turner who leads this
project and Chu
walk you through the some of the
experiments we're currently conducting
and the technologies we're using as well
as the analysis approach we are
utilizing right now for this for this
data set we thank you very much for that
great introduction to our research and
thank you everyone for listening to our
presentation we're really excited to
share what we have here so I'm going to
go a little bit more now into our study
design looking in particular at the
inter individual differences between
micro rna's both intracellular and
exosome and mRNA expression and some of
the relationships between those for our
first slide here we just have the study
design for this particular experiment
this study was designed to include six
different individual cell lines there
from six unique donors all female all
african-american and three are
unaffected so the donors had normal less
than tricular mass and three are from
moderate to severe ly affected lb masa
representing LVH what's critical here
though is both gender and ethnicity of
the donor cell line can substantially
affect expression in the cell model so
matching both of those things is
critical for experimental design
so the very first step that we did after
generating the cell lines was to
characterize these and look at in our
model do we see mRNA expression
differences that reflect our phenotype
of the donors so do these cells have
differential expression for markers of
hypertrophy and when we looked at the
results we just see that yes indeed
these cells do Express classical
hypertrophy markers differently between
the affected and unaffected cell lines
as you can see here this is the samples
six samples were represented here three
from donors with a high LV mass and
three from normal LV mass control lines
the library preparation was done on the
Illumina truth seek and sequencing was
about 50 million paired-end reads per
sample and here you can see we had
significant differential expression in
NPPB and PPA active on corn as well as
other markers of hypertrophy
so after establishing that our cells are
recapitulating aspects of our disease
phenotype the next step was to get a
more in-depth more comprehensive look at
what was going on in our model so for
that we moved our data into the
ingenuity pathway analysis or IPA and
this allowed us to ask what's next and
to do some more complex modeling
understanding some more of these RNA
interactions that were happening
so for the mRNA expression analysis the
first step was to determine what we were
loading into IPA so for our analysis we
looked at genes with differential
expression between the three LVH and
three control cell lines that had a
false discovery rate of less than or
equal to 0.05 the raw data for this was
aligned to HD 19 he 'men reference using
RNA star and the GG mean cat was based
on gene code version 19 the differential
analysis was performed in our using the
EC 2 and we'll come back to that a
little later when we talk about other
ways to look at data to plug in to ITA
and the three affected cell lines and
the three unaffected samples were
treated as biological replicates so
after the initial data was put together
it was uploaded into IPA and there the
first step was to create a core analysis
and the analysis type we're going to
look at is expression analysis and then
the measurement type is the expression
log ratio
you
so after running a core analysis you get
a summary screen and on that summary
screen there'll be several metrics that
will show different different outputs in
different summaries of your data so for
our analysis we want to look at several
things the first thing we can look at is
the analysis settings which is give an
overview of the different metrics that
went into your analysis the next parts
that we can look at includes top
canonical pathways which represents
enriched pathways that are significantly
differentially expressed between your
different cell lines so this is between
our lv8 chai and OVH normal cells
those were the enriched top canonical
pathways that had differential
expression the next step was to look at
top diseases and tox factors and bio
factors sorry and from there we can look
then at upstream regulators disease and
bio functions tox functions top
regulators top networks all of these
things are ones that were enriched in
the data sets that were differentially
expressed between our two cohorts and
here we can see again top disease
functions and then when we look at top
tox functions for ours it was great to
see that we saw cardiotoxicity
was highly enriched and then we can see
the tox list included cardiac
hypertrophy as well as other markers
that fit in with the disease phenotype
of the patients
if we look at top analysis ready
molecules this pulls out the top
molecules that showed significant
differential expression between the two
cohorts
from here we can move on to canonical
pathways so IPA allowed us to enrich for
the top canonical pathways that were
differentially expressed in our two data
sets here we can go design custom charts
and we're able to customize to look at
whatever different metrics we want to
filter our data by and from there we can
move on to upstream analysis and this
allows us to look at activated or
inhibited molecules in our pathways that
are predicted to impact different
networks and from here we can also
customize the table and what we can see
here is that we can determine we can
look at other metrics such as bias term
p-value of overlap and we can select and
filter this way depending on what we're
interested in
the next step that we can look at for
further narrowing down our disease
phenotype is diseases and functions and
on diseases and functions it will show
which either decreasing or increasing
which diseases and functions and which
pathways are significantly enriched in
our phenotype
we can see here is this also enables you
to select individual molecules that are
found in the different pathways and then
to expand upon those molecules with the
background information in the literature
the next step would be to look at
regulator effects and here it will pull
out regulator pathways and regulator
molecules that are significantly
expressed in our our data set and here
we can also then expand upon different
diseases so for this one in particular
this was cardio Genesis so this was a
pathway that is significantly
differentially expressed in our data
sets between the donors that had LVH and
those that had normal LV mass
IPA also allows us to pull out the talks
list enrichment and here we can see the
bar graph showing the subset of the
significantly enriched toxicity list
using the differentially expressed data
in our data set and interestingly heart
failure cardiac arrhythmia cardiac
dilation and infarction as well as
several other known disease pathways are
significantly enriched in our data
next step then would be to see is to
break down these pox lists and these
things more so to look at network so
what networks are significantly enriched
in the data set and the network tab
allows us to pull up the most
significantly enriched networks that we
find differential expression in and
interestingly cardiovascular disease was
our top and rich network so by selecting
network one we're able to expand it
further and it will pull out all of the
molecules and their interactions in this
particular network and then it will
overlay our actual data on our actual
expression level that were
differentially expressed between our two
data sets with green being a lower in
expression and red being increased in
expression between the data sets this
can further be expanded by clicking on
overlay which will then allow us to
overlay different diseases and different
pathways with our datasets so for
example if we were interested in looking
at how cardiovascular disease overlapped
with this particular pathway we would
select that perform it and then it would
highlight all of the molecules that in
addition does this network we're also
present in cardiovascular disease and
then based off of the color of the
circles we could determine which
molecules in our pathway overlaps with
those with differential expression the
next step then will be to actually look
used IPA to a capacity analysis with
gene expression changes so by selecting
on the pathways we can overlay our data
with those pathways again with the same
scale showing increased measurement and
decrease measurement and see which
aspects of specific pathways that our
data is enriched for this allows us
viewing of a pathway with gene
expression changes in addition the IPA
also allows us to do pathway expression
predictions so this will overlay our
actual data then with literature based
or knowledge based finding a finding so
is our data or our findings consistent
with what the literature says these
pathways should be doing for example if
we see over expression of a molecule is
that consistent with what literature
says in this particular pathway should
be happening in association with our
phenotype from there it's capable of
predicting the upstream and downstream
pathway expression changes based off of
the input data and we can then further
expand the pathways by selecting these
networks and we can grow them out and
look at additional molecules that we saw
in our data set and the term
and if they're also consistent or
inconsistent with what literature is
showing through these different pathways
so at that point we've fully or more
further characterized our mRNA
expression differences and we have seen
that we do see significant differences
in the donors are the cell lines that
come from donors with normal LV mass and
those that come from donors with left
ventricular hypertrophy so then my next
step or my next interest was to look at
the micro RNA expression between these
cell lines so the study design for our
intracellular micro RNA analysis was
generating next generation sequencing
libraries prepared from 50 nanograms of
total RNA using the chiastic micro and a
library kit for each of our three LV
Mathai and three control cell lines
sequencing was performed on the next
week five hundred and then sequencing
output was mapped to Mir based version
21 using the Chi seek micro RNA primary
analysis pipelines and this Maps the raw
reads to the micro RNAs as well as
clusters associated with unique
molecular indices and accounting needs
micro RNA molecules and we'll talk a
little bit about the UM eyes in a minute
so the first step then I'm just going to
first go through kind of a quick
overview of the Chi seek micro RNA
workflow the first steps is to extract
the sample so this is RNA extraction
this can be done with several different
kits can be in my RNA seek is the xor
NAC can't the packaging micro RNA kit or
really any other kit that generates high
quality total RNA the next step is to
then perform the T DNA synthesis and
library construction and in this
particular case it was done using the
kiya seek micro in a library kid then
sequencing is performed and that's done
on several next-generation platforms it
could be Illumina on toerner or any
other platform that's compatible with
the library kit and then data analysis
is done the first step is to use the
kiya seek micro and a pathway and we'll
look at both primary and secondary
analysis and then the data
interpretation is done using IPA to take
the primary and secondary analysis and
plug that data into IPA and really do an
interpretation of our results
so just to kind of explain this a little
bit further
the Coyotes Mike Renee library
construction kit utilizes a really
powerful technique when it uses it
indexes um I'm sorry ladies on a unique
molecular indicee at this point um
during library construction this unique
index is assigned to each individual
molecule of RNA and an example of the
way that this can help with your
sequence analysis is shown on this slide
here where you can see for example we
have two genes gene one and the original
RNA whether this is from a single cell
or this is from a pool of RNA gene one
has three transcripts gene two has two
transcripts you integrate the um I so
every single unique micro RNA molecule
at this point is assigned a unique um I
10 and then those go to the library prep
and through sequencing and here you can
see that even though you started out
with 3 to 2 a ratio of 3 to 2
after sequencing you end up with a ratio
that is 2 to 1 however if you go back
and be identified based off of a unique
molecular indices tag you can actually
see that your ratio your true ratio is 3
to 2 based off with a number of unique
molecules that were in your original
data set so this is a really powerful
tool to help remove amplification bias
or sequencing bias from your data
another really interesting a really nice
feature of the library prep is that the
kiya Sikh micro RNA kits are the
libraries generated from these are
significantly enriched for micro RNA
libraries and miss out on a lot of the
adapter divert that you can sometimes
see when your sequencing micro rna's
so after we did the high-speed microwave
library prep the first steps in is to do
the primary data analysis primary data
analysis is done with adapter trimming
read mapping and then um I counting if
you go to the kyochon comm a gene globe
website they're actually our software
pathways to do this but some of the
things you can look at here are the
species so you can look at human rat
mouse or other in our case it was human
you can do adapter trimming to remove
the adapter sequences from the reads you
can do read mapping to identify the
possible positions of the reads within
several reference sequences and then you
can align the read sequences to your own
reference sequences then you can also do
um I accounting and that will merge the
unique um eyes with the mapped reads
so the next step after that is primary
data analysis output and what you'll get
from that is a summary report and you'll
see a summary tab you'll have a micro
RNA tab that has the read the map trees
and the um I accounts for each of the
micro rna's are their small RNAs found
in your base and they also have a tab
that's not characterized mapable reads
which will have map reads and um I
counts for each of the sequence that
align to the genome
they'll look something like this
depending on what your data input was so
at that point you've done the primary
data analysis and then you move on to
the secondary data analysis and the
secondary data analysis can also be done
to the kaijin site and what you can do
here is you can perform differential
gene expression and there are several
ways to normalize the data some of these
are listed here we did Dec 2 in our data
set and then what the output you get
from this is instead of just read counts
you now have full regulation results as
well as scatter plots or some other ways
of visualizing the data and you have a
file that's uploaded into IPA analysis
and here is an example then this is
after we did all of the sequencing for
the micro rna's for the intracellular
micro rna's between our cohorts we
looked at the Reliant um eyes and then
we looked at the differentially
expressed genes and that are inside the
differentially expressed micro rna's and
then that file was uploaded into IPA and
a core analysis was performed and from
here we can then look at several
different features we can see not only
the differential gene expression but it
also enables us to look at mRNA target
prediction so we're able to upload since
we had mRNA expression data for the same
cells that we had the micro RNA
expression data for we can upload our
data set that has the differentially
expressed mRNA in our cohorts and align
it with our differentially expressed
micro RNA and then that will that will
allow us to look then at target
prediction so what we want to do now
though is we want to look at expression
pairing and the expression pairing will
allow us then to filter our micro rna's
based off of those that behave in the
way that we would expect with an inverse
relationship so our interest since we're
looking for micro RNAs that are
potentially regulating differential gene
expression between our two cohorts is to
look at micro rna's where the micro RNA
is up and the mRNA is down or the micro
RNA is down and the mRNA is up and this
will allow us to filter for those and
that point then you can see that we've
narrowed down our list of micro rna's to
277 micro rna's targeting 76 genes now
these these are ones with differential
expression in both the micro RNA and the
mRNA between our two datasets the next
step to further narrow this down to
micro rna's of interest to us are then
to filter by specific pathway so this
will enable us then to filter by
pathways that are of interest so for our
disease phenotype we're interested in
cardiovascular pathways so we would
filter by cardiovascular signaling and
that further narrowed it down to 27
micro rna's targeting 10m are targeting
depth M mRNAs we can then expand upon
this and look at the different pathways
that are affected by these mRNAs and
micro RNAs and here you can see you can
again do an overlay and you can overlay
specific disease and functions onto your
particular micro rna's so this allows us
to see in between our two datasets so in
the
tween are healthy cohort and our disease
cohorts which micro rna's are
differentially expressed and also which
mRNAs are differentially expressed and
then which pathways are is this
affecting this allows us to expand upon
the data further here to where we can
upload again additional datasets so here
we can see in our mRNA expression level
we actually can see the expression
directions and which of our targets was
affected in this particular
cardiovascular pathway
and here we can continue expanding on
this and then this allows us to do the
prediction also of our results
consistent with literature for these
particular pathways so are we finding
something that someone has shown to
regulate cardiac hypertrophy and that
we're also seeing differential
expression for in our data set oops so
now we're jumping to the next topic so
at this point we've characterized the
mRNA and the intracellular micro RNA and
our data set and we have shown that
based off of the phenotype of the donor
you do see differential expression
profiles and expression patterns between
our cardio myocyte cell lines so the
next step for us then was to look at are
we seeing differential expression
between our phenotypic cell lines when
we look at the exosomes and a little bit
of background on exosomes is that
exosomes are packaged into the silver
micro rna's immature mRNA and sorry
immature micro rna's mature micro rna's
and other RNAs that are packaged into
vesicular bodies that are then released
into the extracellular space and then
this is just an example of what can be
found in these particular body it
includes a whole host of different micro
rna's for many different families as
well as small RNAs proteins and other
elements that are released by the cells
into circulation
so an art interest then is looking at
what role are these exosomes playing in
the cardiovascular system since our
disease phenotype is less than tricular
hypertrophy and heart disease we want to
see what a specific micro rna's our
exposome of microRNAs are affecting our
cell model and what are they doing and
what are they so we want to look at the
exosomes in relationship to the
cardiovascular system and there is some
knowledge now based it's known that
cardio arms right exosomes are released
from cardiomyocytes as well as other
cell types into circulation in the human
body and those might as those episodes
are taken up in the micro rna's are
shared between different cell types so
what we wanted to look at then was in
our model of left ventricular
hypertrophy and our cell line model what
are the differentially expressed
micronesia so the first step to do that
is to isolate the X's ohms and prepares
a library so X's omma lice elation and
total RNA isolation was performed using
the XOR and easy serum plasma kit from
kaijin which can do both serum and cell
culture media
just this is a really nice image of what
you actually get from these so
ultracentrifugation is a
well-established method of isolating
exosomes from both serum in cell culture
media however you do see kind of broken
down and identify structures our
particulates that aren't quite matching
the size that look like they may be
ruptured vesicles whereas the Aleut from
the X so easy can't you actually see a
higher ratio of in text intact vesicles
with a higher purity so the next step
was after we isolated the exosomes
and isolated the RNA from those exosomes
library generation and sequencing was
performed exactly the same as it was for
the intracellular Mike Ranney so the
RNAs were assigned the UM I they were
run through the high seek they were then
analyzed doing the primary and secondary
analysis and then those results the
differentially expressed micro rna's
from the exosomes
were plugged into IPA for additional
pathway analysis and here we can see
that you upload it and do your core
analysis and it shows like we saw with
the intracellular micro RNA we actually
see all of the differentially expressed
excess zonal micro rna's and from here
since from here we can actually then add
in an mRNA data set of experiments we
validated or predicted targets based off
of several repositories of micro RNA
targeting kind of primarily looking at
predicted 3 prime UTR binding sites some
of which been experimental evaluated or
just computationally validated we can
overlay that data with our data by
uploading them by clip selecting the
micro RNA target filter and then that
enables us to show all of the predicted
targets of our differentially expressed
micro rna's and our X's o mole fraction
and here again we've narrowed down our
list of micron is we can also sort by
what was the data set used to predict
the target we can sort by what was the
confidence so are these mRNA targets
ones that have been validated
experimentally where people have shown
they are confirmed targets are these
just ones with moderate or high
experimental prediction and we can also
look at then also filtering down by like
pathway but so far in our case we would
be interested in potentially adding a
pet so we could also look at disease or
location or molecule type there are
several ways to filter down
your data to look for what you're most
interested in your model so our interest
is looking at cardiovascular disease
again so at this point we can narrow it
down to 147 microRNAs targeting over
17,000 different genes that have been
predicted using this so if we do narrow
it down to cardiovascular signaling
we've now narrowed it down 247 micro
rna's targeting 1025 predicted targets
and then from here we can expand upon
the different pathways and we can see
then where our targets again lie in
these pathways and then further
overlaying it and so at this point we've
looked at the difference we expressed
mRNA in our data set the differentially
expressed intracellular micro rna's and
the differentially expressed EXO zonal
microRNAs and here we can see in the
differentially expressed X's Ola micro
rna's we see pathways such as cardiac
hypertrophy signaling not signaling
enopp signaling and then the role of in
fat and cardiac hypertrophy
so then as the next step in is to start
thinking how do the exes Domo library so
the differentially expressed exes OMA
microRNAs how do those compared to the
differentially expressed intracellular
microRNAs an IPA allows us to perform a
comparison and with those you elect
compare and then you would upload your
intracellular and your XML data sets or
whatever to set the micro rna's you were
interested in looking at and then you
would select compare and it will allow
you then to compare the ratio of
differentially expressed microRNAs that
are unique to one set unique to the
second set and then what microRNAs are
differentially expressed in both data
sets and interestingly here we find that
distinct micro rna's are differentially
expressed in the EXO's OMA and
intracellular fractions and this is
really pointing towards more complex
mechanism of micro RNA packaging into
the extracellular vesicles
and then if we further expand upon that
idea if we look at the predicted target
or the validated targets of our
intracellular versus exosome 'el
pathways we can see that canonical
pathways for the intracellular targets
include things like the cardiac
hypertrophy signaling and wind signaling
but if we look at the canonical pathways
predicted for our extracellular micro
RNA gene targets we start to include
things like a NOS signaling an
additional network and what that's
really kind of showing here is that the
overlap and pathways such as inside our
cardiac hypertrophy in both the
intracellular and the EXO's OMA micro
rna's likely points to a role in a more
creditable myocyte specific kind of cell
cell neighbor cell communication whereas
the x's onal specific targets like eanes
not signaling or even something like
cardiac fibrosis maybe for distal cell
cell communications for example cardio
myocyte - endothelial cells
so in summary of this we hope that we
shown here is that we've established an
in vitro model that comprehensively
describes the role of microRNAs and
cardio myocyte hypertrophy we have our
model is shown that the H IPS team lines
from our OVH donors exhibit aberrant
micro RNA expression patterns both
intracellularly and X's amelie we've
demonstrated the complexity of the extra
zonal micrornas sembly by distinct
intracellular and exposome micro RNA
expression and then our findings
highlight that there is a really complex
role in circulating microRNAs are
playing in the multi system development
of cardiovascular disease and in
conclusion I just like to thank everyone
at our group at MCW all of our NIH EUL
and participating groups Jonathan at
kiya Jen and then just DNA jin our
American Heart Association and I'll turn
it back over to Ali's well and let me
also finally so thank you to all the
registrants and we also like to thank
kyochon for their support and
collaboration on this project I hope you
felt this presentation be helpful for
your research and informative and as
said in the beginning we will be very
happy to answer any questions you have
related to our presentation today
thank you dr. Brooke oh and miss Turner
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what do you think are critical
components of micro RNA sequencing and
analysis
that is a very good question and and I
think we you know presentation we
already alluded to some of the the
things what we think is challenging so
first of all and you know I wanted to
emphasize this with your work with cell
culture and you're trying to analyze as
we do different you know cell types or
cell lines from different individuals I
mean your overall cell culture and
phenotyping approach who really needs to
be very robots so we would discipline I
spend a lot of time on testing Fridays
however producible our results aren't
really optimizing our cell cause a cell
plating and tell maintenance as well as
RNA collection procedures so I mean if
you're looking at just looking at
different individuals I mean if you just
have variation in the way how your
culture and maintain and collect the
material dead obviously which is you
know bleeds when you would detect it as
differences between the different cell
lines but in fact it's really truly
technical so I think you know we didn't
describe that in detail this is
something we're but we did spend a lot
of time in optimizing this and I would
refer to a me to begin to emphasize some
of the technical logical the approaches
around mRNA and sample collection and
sample sequencing basically I think that
was a great explanation for that and
also in particular for micro RNA
sequencing and mRNA sequencing is that
the quality of your input RNA is
critical to the outcome of your
experiment if you have degraded RNA or
low amount or contamination that will
that can significantly bias your results
as well as accusing your library prep
after a generation of your RNA seek
libraries we kind of hinted at it in
here but with micro RNA sequencing it's
very easy to have a lot of your reads
eaten up by adapter dimer or if you have
degraded RNA by just small degraded
mRNAs and go and so the quality of your
input RNA is critical and as well as the
generation of your libraries those are
true the really critical components pre
sequencing that Goenka to micron a
sequencing
thank you our next question is how do
you explain the difference between
intracellular and XML so mole micro RNA
that is there is also a very good
question so we you know obviously the
you know we maintain a single cell type
culture zone in our cell culture really
only you know these IPS throughout
cardiomyocytes and de cèlle culture
media doesn't contain any micro RNAs as
it is serum-free so the micro rna's we
find in exosomes are truly from from the
cardiomyocytes in cell culture now if
you're again I didn't didn't describe
this in greatest detail but the dis am
playing when we sample the de sel
culture media for the excess thermal
analysis this is about a cell ecology
media where the cells were maintained
for 24 hours and when we then for the
micro RNA intracellular mRNA and micro
RNA analysis that's obviously at the end
of these 24 hours so into some respect
the EXO so mole fraction really reflects
the shedding or the the transport of
release of micro rna's in the cell
culture media over a time period of 24
hours and obviously it's quite
perceivable that certain micro rna's
turned on in the different time points
so there will be one explanation but the
other explanation is and i think there
is also you know growing evidence that
there are there are active processes
which package micro rnas and other
components which you can find in these
extra in these vesicles or the exosomes
actively get transported because you
know these cells actually repeat it as a
mechanism but with interact and
communicate with cell types close by in
in the distance so that those are
probably the most likely explanations
for these differences but obviously i
mean most of the excess and most of the
micro rna's which we see you know are
are also overlapping
you for that answer our next question is
what are your next steps to further
explore your results
I guess the next step sent that further
Explorer results are going to be to look
at the communication between the
exosomes in our cardiomyocytes in two
different cell models so what are the
functional impacts of these exosomes are
having both on other cardiomyocytes as
well as different cell types and then
perform expression analysis and
functional assays of those as well yeah
in addition to that I mean you know as
we try to understand and the the unique
patterns what we see in different
individuals and obviously you know a
more long-term at a more general goal
that we understand disease
characteristic variation between
different individuals we understand that
better and potentially can use this
information to develop biomarkers and
also use this to develop potential new
new treatments so you know as we
understand expression as we understand
the roles of microRNAs and exosomes it
is a big really overarching question is
how can we translate this to to
potentially diagnose patients better
more precisely and with this information
how can we identify potential novel
treatment options
I would like to once again thank dr.
Raquel and Miss Turner for their
presentation I would also like to thank
aya Jen for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through August 10th of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye